hi mystery recap here today i'm going to
explain a sci-fi thriller film called
level 16.
spoilers ahead watch out and take care
[Music]
the movie starts in an all-girls hostel
vivian and sophia are best friends
they talk about being adopted one day
suggesting that the girls are all
orphans the hostile seems to have very
strict rules
at night when the blue lights turn on
all of them go to sleep in their
respective beds without any question
in the morning when the alarm goes off
they all line up in front of the basin
with their respective jar of face cream
and towel to clean themselves
they have to wash their face in front of
a camera even a little bit of sloppiness
can put the girls in big trouble
that day when it's vivian's turn to wash
her face sofia drops her face cream
sophia has bad eyesight so she has
trouble finding the cream
vivian runs to help her so is a little
late for her turn the alarms go off two
guards drag vivian away as she begs them
that she is clean
sophia and the other girl silently face
the wall
the building they live in is an isolated
artificially lit and windowless boarding
school the girls living there have never
seen daylight they have been in the
establishment since they were babies
starting from level zero as they grow
older they move up to higher floors and
higher levels the highest level is level
16. when the girls are in level 16 they
are eligible to be adopted
throughout their lives they have been
taught to be clean and proper they are
schooled in health home skills and
etiquette they are taught that curiosity
and anger are vices that make them less
of a girl
however they are never taught to read
and write
cut to a few years later
vivian and sophia reunite at level 16
but vivian hates sophia for being the
reason she was punished back in level
10.
vivian has now become a top girl who
follows the rules of the academy without
any questions the girls are happy to be
at the last level on their first day in
level 16 they pick a bed for themselves
then take the vitamins one by one
then they go to eat and move on with
their routine life
that day sofia pulls vivian aside in the
bathroom to tell her something but
vivian dismisses her
miss brixel is their supervisor
that day during their assembly she comes
in with good news brixel has brought a
pretty dress for the girls they are
beyond delighted the dresses have their
name embroidered on them
the following day the girls are doing
their chores when sophia trades her
chore with a girl to be with vivian
she then tells her to just pretend to
take the vitamins and not actually take
them before she can tell her the reason
a girl comes looking for vivian and
takes her away vivian doesn't trust
sophia she is skeptical of the idea but
she doesn't take the vitamins that day
later that night all girls fall asleep
except for vivian and sophia
sophia then reveals that the vitamins
are actually sleeping pills and that the
establishment has been drugging the
girls since level one as they talk they
hear footsteps outside the door
so they quickly pretend to be asleep
miss brixel and two guards enter the
room brixel chooses two of the girls
vivian and olivia the guards pick both
of them up and take them to a room
then miss brixel comes in with an old
couple
she tells them about the girls as if
they are good she is trying to sell
the couple chooses olivia they want to
buy her
vivian is shocked to know that they are
not being adopted but bought by rich
families
then she is brought back by the guards
to the room again
vivian finally believes everything that
sophia has said
sophia then reveals that she has not
taken those pills since level 13 every
night she stays awake as the girl sleep
when they got to level 16 the guards
started taking girls out every night to
show them to their clients
when asked what she does at night sophia
reveals that she listens to the girls
outside
when these girls go to sleep the other
levels of girls wake up and do the same
routine
she also tells her about the black hour
where the hallways go silent and every
level of girls is asleep
in that hour a security guard comes into
the room and touches the sleeping girls
inappropriately
as they talk brixel comes into the room
again
this time she takes sophia and one other
girl
after they are gone vivian sees the
doors are unlocked
she is in front of the surveillance
camera but no alarms ring
she then tries to open the door outside
but can't so she goes back to the room
again
soon sophia is brought back too
the following day the girls are taken to
dr miro's clinic he does his monthly
checkup on the girls and injects them
with a chemical
posing it as a vaccine the doctor seems
to be friendly he tells vivian of an
actress of the same name vivian lee and
compliments her smile
later the girls have their movie night
they watch the same movie that they have
been shown for years
that night after the girls fall asleep
vivian and sophia talk about escaping
the building
they know that they need the key card to
open the doors
sophia suggests that they steal it from
the guard that comes in during the black
hour but vivian is against the idea
instead she thinks that dr miro can help
them
the following day she goes to dr miro's
clinic without him calling her she makes
up an excuse about wanting to know what
the actress vivian lee looks like
the doctor lovingly tells her that he
will look into it later that day the
girls are playing some board games when
one of them gets a seizure and starts to
vomit sophia helps her clean up while
one of the girls ava suggests they
should call the guards she assumes that
it is because of the vaccine they were
injected with
that day as the girls are in their
grooming class the video of vivian lee
plays
vivian knows that dr miro put on the
show
at the next doctor's appointment vivian
thanks dr miro but as they talk the
doctor gets suspicious that she has not
been taking her vitamins lately so he
injects her with a drug that will make
her fall asleep the whole day vivian is
hazy she slurs on her words while
talking to sophia and her hair is messy
too ava assumes this is because vivian
is lazy and unclean so she reports it to
ms brixel
she gathers the girls and takes vivian
with her to punish her for being unclean
she then puts her in a tiny cell and
tells her to reflect on her actions
brixel then goes back to her room in the
building
she pours two glasses of alcohol and we
get to know that dr miro and her are
actually a couple
they have a conversation about their
boss who brings the clients
suggesting that they too work for
someone
miro reveals that their boss wants them
to restock on girls brixel is against
the idea she wants to get out of this
business but miro suggests that they
don't have to bring infant girls they
can get some teenagers and admit them to
the establishment
however brixel doesn't agree cut to that
night
vivian is still in the cell while sophia
makes a rope using the bed sheets she
plans to attack the security guard who
comes to harass the girls at night just
then he comes in
when he is about to touch one of the
girls sophia chokes him with a rope
she then rushes outside to free vivian
but before she can the guard attacks her
he is almost about to kill her when she
saves herself by hitting him with an
iron her nightgown is splattered with
blood
she then takes his key card and rushes
to vivian
however the alarm starts to ring
hence sophia runs back to the room
vivian cries and tells her to not leave
her this time
sometime later brixel gets vivian out
and makes her and the other girl stand
in line
miro is there too
they tell the girls that sophia has
betrayed the establishment and will be
punished accordingly then they ask if
the girls have the card that sophia took
no one speaks
turns out that sophia had hidden the
card before she was caught
dr miro is furious he threatens the
girls that he will take each one of them
for a punishment one by one until they
find the card he then asks the guards to
take rita for the punishment she begs
that she hasn't done anything wrong but
the guards take her away
vivian doesn't know where they have
taken sophia brixel is now more strict
with the vitamin rule
she feeds the girls the as vitamins
herself
that night vivian stabs herself with her
hair clipped to try and stay awake
she looks for the card everywhere on
sophia's bed then finds it in the
headboard of her own bed
sophia had left it there to help her
friend run away
vivian tries to open the room door with
it but it doesn't work
then she gets an idea she takes her hair
pin and starts to remove the door
altogether she finally gets out of the
room
then she goes to dr miro's cabin and
finds brixel there brixell tries to
inject vivian with a sedative but she
attacks her and injects her instead
vivian then asks her about sophia's
whereabouts but doesn't get any answer
she then sneaks into the prison cells in
the basement of the building
sophia is in one of the rooms there
using brixel's card she manages to free
her but her hands are zip tied the girls
then find a surgical room with scissors
they use it to cut the zip tie but they
also reveal the body of their friend
rita
she was taken that morning for
punishment the girls are horrified to
see her face has been skinned they are
now determined to run away
sophia wants to warn other girls but
vivian wants to run away so they decide
that sophia will go to the halls and
bring all the girls to a room while
vivian stays there
so sophia goes in and collects as many
girls as she can
meanwhile as vivian waits for her she
hears a guard coming towards her
she escapes and hides inside a room
there she finds a tv
a video starts to play
it is an advertisement of some sort dr
miro in the video explains a procedure
to regain your youth by planting a
beautiful donor's face onto your own
vivian realizes that they have been
brought up all these years and raised in
a sterile environment without sunlight
so rich sponsors can pay to get the skin
of these young girls transplanted onto
them to make them appear more youthful
read his face with skin because she was
chosen by a client
elsewhere sophia brings all the girls to
a room
she tries to explain to them what is
happening but the girls do not believe
her they even threatened to call the
guards but just then vivian comes in
with bricks
she is intoxicated because of the
sedative vivian tells them about rita's
skin body downstairs
she then shows them brixel scars
revealing that she too was a client and
was wearing someone's face
the girls now finally believe them
they take brixel to the cell she had put
vivian earlier in and rush out of the
building through the escape door however
the guards find them midway
most of the girls run but sophia is
caught by the guard
he injures her but the girls managed to
push him off the building killing him
then all of them run away in different
directions the guards almost catch
sophia and vivian but they lock
themselves into an abandoned house
dr miro and the guards are outside and
he lovingly tells vivian to come outside
but vivian cuts her face proving that
she is of no use to miro now
the guards get a call from their boss
who orders them to kill miro since he
has failed
that night the girls stay in the room in
the morning they are rescued by two
police officers the movie ends as vivian
and sophia come outside the house and
see the rainfall for the first time in
their lives
subscribe for more videos like this turn
on notifications and leave a like to
help the channel out
thank you for watching